m
la sixième édition du concours de slam
et de danse urbaine s'est déroulée au
théâtre de champ fleuri
une manifestation qui est venu clôturer
la programmation mise en place par le
conseil départemental à l'occasion de la
fête de la musique avec pour parrain
firmin viry un des artistes
emblématiques de l'ul pendant près de
six heures les 19 collèges participants
ont évolué sur scène et ont partagé
leurs émotions à travers des textes ou
des danses
ah ah
des prestations à la hauteur des
attentes du jury composé cette année
d'artistes professionnels et de
représentants du conseil départemental
des jeunes et nous on a noté surtout
l'originalité la création et puis
l'application
donc voila et puis après il y avait un
barème de notes qu'on a quand même bien
respectée pour essayer d'être au plus
proche du professionnalisme on va dire
je vous n'était pas vraiment ce milieu
avec des belles compositions qu'on voit
que
un collège on était bien
moi ça m'a plus franchement je sens ce
qui a fait la différence c'est vraiment
le tout poil et coutumes sarac telle
histoire
la mise en scène
les déplacements la technique
eve marolles présidente du conseil
départemental des jeunes faisait
également partie du jury
pour elle ce concours est le moyen pour
mettre en avant les jeunes et découvrir
des artistes de demain
ces jeunes là qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
sur scène ce sont donc des musiciens des
danseurs des chanteurs des slameurs et
j'en passe
mais ce sont simplement les artistes de
demain alors c'est maintenant qu'il faut
les valoriser
puisque on les voit ils sont dans la rue
ils ont dans les collèges chez eux alors
il faut se dire que 1 - ce qui monte sur
scène et fois qu'ils montent de quoi ils
sont capables quoi l'ambiance était bel
et bien au rendez vous une sixième
édition triomphante avec un public qui a
enflammé le théâtre de champ fleuri
le premier prix dans la catégorie slam
revient au collège des aigrettes pour la
danse urbaine le premier prix a été
attribué ou que les gens l'écoutent